I was curious how did you come to the
decision to name the cat goose instead
of sticking the Chewie you know it
wasn't that wasn't a big it wasn't a big
thing it just felt like Star Wars was so
part of the culture that it just felt
like we wanted to remove it a little bit
you know the the nostalgia for the Star
Wars movies which are there so many of
around us you know when we were when we
were kids Star Wars felt like it was
something from the 70s and 80s and I
think that was the spirit of Chewie from
the comics but we felt like we wanted to
sort of just slide away from that's like
yeah and just like the idea of having a
reference that would have been so
specific to Carol Danvers past as her
past in the movie itself being a pilot
in the 1980s when Top Gun was out and
having a reference that felt a little
bit more specific to her whereas Chewie
when the comics were being written was a
very specific reference in time but now
with like all the movies out it feels
you know more contemporary and not so
specific to her past understandable
you